did you watch the Super Bowl I did it
was a fantastic game crazy game yeah
yeah a really excellent game and even
though it was a tough loss for my team
the Patriots I thought the game was
incredibly exciting 4322 4325 four
thousand three hundred and twenty eight
okay excuse me I'm sorry that's that's
Tony that's one of our cameramen Tony
why are you counting out loud
I'm sorry Conan I have to count out loud
otherwise the numbers get lost in my
brain math is a doozy yeah
Tony I'm just curious where'd you get
all the money oh these are my Super Bowl
winnings yeah oh did you bet on the
Eagles oh wow that would have been so
smart damn it no I just parlayed about a
dozen prop bets and get this I want
every single one of them Oh
congratulations don't you and what were
some of the bet huh well one of them
definitely wasn't I bet that Andy will
annoy the crap out of me while I'm
trying to have a nice conversation with
Conan just just tell us some of the bets
Tony okay here are all the bets and
remember I had to win all of these
otherwise I wouldn't get it done I bet a
hundred bucks that Nick Foles would
throw three touchdown passes and and
that he would catch a touchdown pass and
that James White's longest carry would
be for 26 yards and that the TV cameras
would show Bradley Cooper at least four
times and that the Old Spice guy would
show up in an ad for Tide detergent Wow
Tony those bets are specific hey Andy
you know what's specific the specific
way you annoy the crap out of me
whoa wait a minute Tony Andy's right
those bets do seem weirdly specific a
very good point Conan I guess you could
say that my bets are even suspiciously
specific anyway here are the rest of the
bets I bet that the halftime score would
be 22 to 12 Eagles and that the Eagles
would score 12 points in the fourth
quarter and that Corey Clement would
score a receiving touchdown and that my
girlfriend Savannah would say wait the
Patriots have a Gronkowski and a
Gostkowski that's so dumb and that Tom
Brady who get the ball strip from his
throwing hand with exactly 2 minutes and
13 seconds left in the game and then
after the ball was stripped from his
hand he'd continue with the throwing
motion anyway specifically in a kind of
that's insane there's no way you could
have predicted all that oh there is one
way Conan the gamble Tron 5000 it's the
only time machine for degenerate
gamblers like me
here your winnings mr. O'Brien eight
million dollars oh thank you very much
Demetri Wow
Conan what did you bet on I bet that you
all wouldn't have a good ending for this
sketch
and on the tonin show it's a safe bet
every time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
you